we already know that an angle is formed
when two rays share a common endpoint so
for example let's say that this is one
ray right over here and then this is one
another array right over here and then
they would form an angle and this point
right over here their common endpoint is
called the vertex of that angle
now we also know that not all angles
seem the same for example this is one
angle here and then we could have
another angle we could have another
angle that looks something that looks
something like something like this that
looks something like this and viewed
this way it looks like this one is much
more this is much more open so i'll say
more open
more open and this one right over here
seems less open
so to avoid having to just say oh more
open and less open and actually becoming
a little bit more exact about it we
actually want to measure how open an
angle is or we want to have a measure of
the angle
now the most typical way that angles are
measured there's actually two major ways
that they're measured the one the most
typical unit is in degrees but later on
in high school you will also see the
unit of
radians being used especially when you
learn trigonometry but the degrees
convention really comes from a circle so
let's draw ourselves a circle right over
here so that's a circle
and the convention is is that a when i
say a convention it's just kind of what
everyone has been doing
the convention is is that you have 360
degrees in a circle so let me explain
that so if that's the center of the
circle
and if we make this ray
are
our kind of our starting point or or one
side of our angle if you go all the way
around the circle if you go all the way
around the circle that represents 360
degrees
360 degrees and the notation is 360 and
then this little superscript circle
represents degrees this could be read as
360 degrees now you might be saying
where did this 360 number come from and
no one knows for sure but there's some
type of there's hints in history and
there's hints in in just the way that
the the universe works or at least the
earth's rotation around the sun you
might recognize or you might already
realize that there are 365
days in a non-leap year 366 in a leap
year and so you could imagine ancient
astronomers might have said well you
know that's pretty close that's pretty
close to that's pretty close to
360. that's pretty close to 360. and in
fact several ancient calendars including
the persians and the mayans had
360 days in their year and 360 is also a
much neater number than 365. it has many
many more factors it's divisible it's
another way of saying it's divisible by
a bunch of things but anyway this has
just been the convention once again what
history has handed us that a circle
where is viewed to have 360 degrees
and so the one way we could measure an
angle
is you could put one of the rays of an
angle right over here at this part of
the circle and then the other ray of the
angle
the other area of the angle will look
something like this
and then the fraction of the circle
that's intersected by these two rays the
fraction of the circle circumference
that is intersected by these two rays
the measure of this angle would be that
fraction of degrees so for example so
for example let's say that this right
over here this right over here this
length right over here
is 1 6
of the circle's circumference
circumference
so it's 1 6 of the way around the circle
then this angle right over here is going
to be 1 6 of 360 degrees so in this case
this would be 60 degrees i could do
another example so let's say i had a
circle like this
and i'll draw
an angle i'll put the vertex at the
center of the angle i'll put one of the
rays right over here you could consider
that to be zero degrees or the right
side if the other angle if the other
array was also here would be zero
degrees and then i'll make the other
array of this angle
let's say it went straight up
let's say it went straight up like this
well in this situation the arc
the arc that connects these two
endpoints just like this
this represents one-fourth of the
circumference of the circle this is
right over here 1 4
of
the circumference
circumference
circumference so this angle right over
here is going to be 1 4 of 360 degrees
360 degrees divided by 4 is going to be
90 degrees and an angle like this one
where one ray is straight up and down
and the other one is goes to the right
left direction we would call this a
perpendicular angle or we would say
these two rays are perpendicular or we
would call this a right angle and the
way that we often times will denote that
is by a symbol like this but this
literally means a 90 degree angle let's
do one more example let's do one more
example of this just to make sure that
we understand what's going on actually
let's yeah at least one more example
maybe one more if we have time
so let's say that we have an angle that
looks like this one once more i'm going
to put its center i'm going to put its
vertex at the center of the circle
that's one ray of the angle
and let's say
that this is the other ray
this right over here is the other ray of
the angle i encourage you to pause this
video and tell and and try to figure out
what the measure what the measure of
this angle right over here is
well let's think about where the rays
intersect the circle they intersect
there and there the arc that connects
them on the circle is that arc right
over there that is literally half of the
circumference of the circle that is half
of the circumference half of the way
around of the circle
circumference
of the circle so this angle is going to
be half of 360 degrees and half of 360
is
180 degrees and when you view it this
way these two arrays share a common
endpoint and together they're really
forming a line here and let's just do
one more example because i said i would
let me
paste another circle let me draw another
angle
let me draw another angle
so let's say that's one ray of the angle
and this is the other ray
this is the other ray of the angle
right over here and we care there's
actually two angles that are formed
there's actually two angles formed in
all of these
there's one angle that's formed right
over here and you might recognize that
to be a 90 degree angle but what we
really care about in this example is
this angle right over here
so once again where does it intersect
the circle we care about this arc right
over here because
that's the arc that is that corresponds
to this angle right over here and it
looks like we've gone three-fourths
around the circle so this angle is going
to be three-fourths of six of
360 degrees one-fourth of 360 degrees is
90. so three of those is going to be
270 degrees